welcome to this video playing David root
car one David would go on
what sky is twelve hundred in one minute
eighteen hundred in three minutes and mm
anyway let's see what happens here yeah
the Budapest are playing this somewhat
weird line but my experience is pretty
good with it my results I don't have
four it's doing a good job in
controlling okay what is this
there's Bishop Queen age four or
something okay trading is not a big deal
snipe does a good job of controlling d5
no I'm threatening c5 strategically okay
how do I get developed TM maybe just
Bishop t2 I would like to fianchetto but
not with the bishop on f6 yeah this is
one of the things about the Budapest
there's always a knight coming to d5
okay then he is going back or what yep
Knight b5 maybe putting more pressure
that's the trade of that that's Bishop I
don't know maybe and for was an idea as
well but this look looks quite okay both
recaptures makes some sense
I mean look one rook takes and Knight b5
takes c3
I'm not quite sure where I wanted to go
with the ruckus I'm taking with the
night
aha night - aah
that's a very attractive-looking move
I'm not quite sure what to do though I
mean it's it's nice for white but don't
have a clear clear way forward and the
other thing is that guy is a machine
yeah this is clearly an engine so I'm
quite quite curious of what what might
happen here is playing every move after
five seconds one two three four five one
two three
Wow one two three four five move one two
three four five myth
one two three four okay some obvious
ones he plays quicker and the whole the
whole wood stuff yeah yeah with Queen h4
then back in Nigeria this is just
typical computer [ __ ] and the whole
account is just wreaking anyway with the
with the with the very bad ratings and
everything besides five minute
the only thing that irritates me about
this is that I have a really great
position c-5a Blunden c5 yeah yeah of
course of course it's a computer it's a
computer yeah yeah of course
five seconds not immediately and not
taking the rook immediately what an
idiot yeah
what a damn idiot you really have those
cheaters currently there it's really a
pasture check it's really a pest I don't
know what's going on down I mean it
always was it was happening really I
mean it's nothing new but currently it's
getting really really bad I think is the
position isn't even easier I mean he had
to play this himself he would probably
lose this in a heartbeat
I have pretty good compensation for the
exchange mmm okay let's just stay maybe
I can win on time if it takes five five
seconds every move maybe
yeah the whole account will smell the
cluttered did you offered maybe I can
even on time you're so damn slow because
you cannot you cannot no no you know no
you see the time is getting a problem
right now maybe you can now draw because
of repetition let's let's avoid that and
see what happens and now he's playing
himself let's see what happens the
problem is that the position isn't that
great
you check summer lost is nerve there ok
maybe I can invade now he's playing
himself let's see what happens
that's a nice person baby I'm going to
push that all the way home check check
mm what now what are you learning now
resigns our resigns it's bad yeah if you
have to play some moose yourself
unbelievable stuff yeah mom okay I don't
know what to make of that game I mean
the whole thing is I mean it's it reeks
from the get-go all right
you look at that profile yeah he's got
relatively bad ratings it's a relatively
new account that's the first thing
yeah he's called the terror relatively
bad three-minute rating one minute is
out of this world really bad and then
he's got 2,400
in five minute Blitz rating is
relatively bad but okay it might happen
he just lost two games and it's just out
of ten games and bullet is just two
games whatever here but three minutes on
1800 and five minute or two for this is
not happening and you're not having a
one-minute rating of 1200 either yeah if
you are a good five-minute player you at
least have like 2,000 or something yeah
okay
this is the first thing then first of
all I mean playing a somewhat irregular
opening is pretty usual for those guys
they rarely play main lines and see five
seconds three seconds it always takes a
couple of seconds even the most obvious
moves ever the recaptures and so on the
next thing that looks in immensely fishy
is this business screen age form and
then back because I mean g3 is super
obvious and then back and no human would
do that because g3 I mean it's not even
a weakness on my hand it's just it's
just stupid I mean black doesn't suffer
here or so hurt it just doesn't make any
sense to go for that and then here we
had this Andy went he went back yeah
went back to a8 yeah maybe this is the
better move and Queen d8 but still
yeah then queenly to where we had to
have those trades and again he was
spending five seconds for every move
yeah and then we continued have
blundered that exchange but fortunately
for me it isn't that clear yeah it isn't
that easy and I could shuffle around and
he was taking time for every move and
when he was down to one minute versus
one foot he offered that draw which I
declined because I felt okay maybe I
went on time but then he started to play
himself and screwed up that hook and
came back twelve moves or so yeah so
create Sheeta and in one in this case it
was actually punished because he
couldn't get his act together at the end
when he had to play that that position
himself yeah I was still report him
thanks for watching